On July 13, 1944, William James Sidis’s
landlord found him unconscious in his small
Boston boarding house.
He had suffered a massive stroke.
And lay dying.
William may have been the smartest person
who ever lived.
His IQ was somewhere between 250 and 300.
To put that in perspective, Einstein’s was
estimated to be 200.
William’s parents were brilliant Ukrainian
Jewish immigrants.
Boris Sidis was a renowned psychologist, Sarah
Sidis went to medical school at a time when
few women did.
William - or Billy as he was known - learned
the alphabet by six months of age.
At 18 months, he could read the New York Times.
He enrolled at Harvard University at age 11!
When he graduated, William told reporters
he intended to live the “perfect life”.
But that would not come to be.
William James Sidis was born on April Fool’s
Day, 1898, in New York City.
Violent anti-Semitic attacks in Ukraine, which
was then part of the Russian empire, drove
his parents to the promised land, where they
met when Boris tutored Sarah in English.
She encouraged him to go to Harvard, where
he studied psychology and used some of his
psychological principles to help mold his
son.
He said: “You know the old saying - ‘As
the twig is bent, the tree’s inclined.’
Parents cannot too soon begin the work of
bending the minds of their children in the
right direction…”
William’s parents attributed his extraordinary
intelligence not to genes but to his upbringing.
As a baby, they treated him like an adult.
When he was a few months old, William’s
parents placed food and a spoon in front of
him.
They let William observe, and he learned to
feed himself.
His mum recalled: “He squealed with delight.
No one had taught him; he had reasoned it
out.”
This natural way of reasoning is also how
his parents taught him how to spell.
Instead of learning through memorization,
William learned to spell by focusing on the
underlying patterns and structures.
For example, if he learned the word “BAT”
using letter blocks, then he understood that
modifying the word by, say, swapping out the
“a” for an “e” would form a new word
with a different meaning.
In the same way that he learned to spell,
William learned eight languages by the age
of eight by understanding the fundamental
principles of language structure.
Besides English, he knew: Latin, Greek, German,
Russian, Hebrew, Turkish, French, and Armenian.
He even invented his own language as a child,
Vendergood which drew on European influences.
Instead of reading him fairy tales at bedtime,
his parents read him Greek myths, which helped
him learn about the planets.
Jupiter is named after the Roman god Jupiter
which is adapted from Zeus in Greek mythology.
Every moment was an opportunity to learn.
William had no time for or interest in playing
with toys.
He didn’t play sports or any games at recess.
His father thought such childish pursuits
were silly and meaningless.
For some reason, he had a tremendous fear
of dogs.
His only enjoyment was riding on streetcars
when his parents took him to museums, libraries,
parks, and zoos.
He collected 1,600 streetcar transfers by
the time he was in his twenties.
William ended up finishing elementary school
in less than one year, and high school in
six weeks.
His mom remarked: “The newspapers never
missed a chance to try and prove that he was
insane, or psychotic, or simply a freak.
In truth, Billy was a completely normal child
in every respect.”
The media attention followed him to Harvard.
Where they portrayed him as a “know it all”,
like in this New Yorker cartoon where he’s
lecturing to a group of men.
After entering Harvard at age 11, he gave
a lecture to the Math Club about the fourth
dimension, which is an extension beyond the
3D space we experience.
Here, he’s talking about shapes with many
sides in the fourth dimension, which demonstrates
his astounding ability to comprehend complex
mathematical concepts beyond his years.
A professor at MIT who attended the lecture
proclaimed: “I predict that young Sidis
will be a great astronomical mathematician.”
Yet, this never happened.
In fact, he would grow to resent mathematics.
Shortly after the lecture, he fell ill, which
made all the news.
The media reported that he had suffered a
mental breakdown which was a rumor that dogged
him his entire life.
He did live with his family on an estate in
New Hampshire that was also the grounds of
the sanatorium Boris was running.
(Sidis Psychotherapeutic Institute)
William only returned to Harvard several months
later and never fit in.
His biographer Amy Wallace described how he
was: “A complete freak in the eyes of his
fellow students, he had none of the social
graces, no interest in sports or girls, and
was several years younger.”
When he graduated from Harvard, he told reporters,
"I want to live the perfect life.
The only way to live the perfect life is to
live it in seclusion.
I have always hated crowds.”
His idea of the perfect life is described
in a paper he wrote utopian society called
Hesperia.
Hesperia’s Constitution begins with: “We,
the people”, reminiscent of the U.S. Constitution.
But that was where the similarities end.
In Hesperia, those who want citizenship have
to pass an intelligence test.
Marriage is forbidden, while polygamy is completely
legal.
Interestingly, children are not raised by
their biological parents, and instead, “Male
children shall be assigned to the charge of
male guardians, and female children to the
charge of female guardians.”
He rejected the influence of his parents,
particularly that of his domineering mother.
After leaving Harvard, he took up a position
teaching mathematics at Rice Institute, now
Rice University in Houston.
He was 17 years old.
Just like at Harvard, William didn’t fit
in at Rice.
Students teased him for never having kissed
a girl.
Girls faked crushes on him as a joke.
He stayed at Rice for only eight months and
then enrolled at Harvard Law School in the
fall of 1916.
Then, for some unknown reason, he quit in
his last semester and failed to earn a law
degree.
His mother was furious and would tell people
that her son left his studies because Harvard
Law had to shut down due to World War I, which
was not true.
William was very much anti-war.
He refused to register for the draft and nearly
went to prison if it weren’t for the armistice
of 1918 that ended the first world war.
He was extremely passionate about politics.
He was briefly jailed after leading a May
Day rally in Boston, an anti-war, workers’
rights rally organized by the Socialists that
turned violent.
organized by the Socialists, organized by
the Socialists, which also conveyed a strong
anti-war message.
He rebelled against the capitalist system
that propelled his parents from their status
as poor immigrants to a position of success
in American society.
While in jail, he met and fell head over heels
for Martha Foley, a 20-year-old Irish girl
who grew up in Boston.
“HARVARD’S BOY PRODIGY VOWS NEVER TO MARRY
SIDIS PLEDGES CELIBACY BENEATH STURDY OAK,
HAS 154 RULES WHICH GOVERN HIS LIFE, ‘WOMEN
DO NOT APPEAL TO ME,’ HE SAYS; HE IS 16.”
Despite telling the Boston Herald earlier
that he vowed to remain celibate, saying,
“Women do not appeal to me.”
After the arrest, he followed Martha to New
York.
They kissed, but Martha assured him there
would be nothing more.
William’s unrequited love may have affected
the trajectory of his life.
William's friend Julius Eichel said: "Sidis
admitted that her love might have achieved
wonders with him…"
He carried a photograph of her in his pocket
until the day he died.
Martha went on to marry a writer and achieved
notoriety for co-founding the literary magazine
Story.
When her memoirs were published, she briefly
mentioned William in a single line, in which
she called him “the famous and tragic prodigy
who was the first boy ever to pay court to
me.”
(72%)
Despite his brilliance, William failed to
achieve greatness.
And any work that did show promise was overlooked.
In 1925, he published a book that challenged
the Second Law of Thermodynamics, the principle
that the universe is headed toward “heat
death” where all energy is evenly spread
out, so there won’t be any energy left to
power any processes.
In this state, nothing will move, change,
or live.
(frozen tableau imagery)
In The Animate and the Inanimate, he explored
the possibility of reversing the universe’s
direction.
He theorized that living things could tap
into a hidden source of energy to counteract
the process.
He gave an example of a ball bouncing down
the stairs, which, when played in reverse
on film, appears as if a hidden source of
energy is pushing the ball up the stairs.
He did acknowledge that his work was speculative
and his theory has never been proven.
But it was never taken seriously in the first
place.
It was ignored.
There wasn’t a single review during its
time.
He made headlines for being a boy prodigy
and for his private life, yet no one paid
attention to his academic work.
He stopped writing about physics, math, and
cosmology altogether.
While in New York, he took on menial jobs,
including working as an operator in an office
that was using an early mechanical calculator
called a comptometer.
The papers were all too keen to splash headlines
about the boy wonder earning an average wage
of $23 bucks a week.
He hid his genius from his co-workers.
When they found out who he was, he’d move
on to the next job.
He refused to accept higher-paying work in
which he had to use his intellect.
Once, he was offered a job with a railway
company that tried to put him to work solving
their technical problems.
One of the officials later found him crying.
William told him he couldn’t bear the thought
of doing math.
Another time, a cousin needed his math skills
to help solve a dental problem involving the
alignment of teeth.
He offered William $3,000, the equivalent
of $55,000 today.
It would have taken him two hours to solve.
But he refused.
William’s biographer concludes: “...he
could not take a job of complex figuring without
risking emotional and physical illness.”
His entire life had been defined by pressure
to perform at a high level.
At the expense of mastering basic life skills.
He confessed to an aunt that he had never
been taught to tie his shoelaces.
His parents may have provided him with an
exceptional education, yet they failed to
teach him the basics of grooming.
He didn’t shave regularly, wore a worn-out
cap.
He reportedly didn’t bathe, or at least
not often, and the stench was brutal.
When his father suffered a stroke and died
in October 1923, he never attended the funeral.
According to William’s biographer, the reason
was that he refused to see his mum.
William hated the way she dominated him as
a child.
They never reconciled.
The Sidis’ didn’t raise their other child
with the same intensity.
William’s younger sister Helena did not
get a formal elementary or high school education.
Helena said that her dad had become so fed
up with William that he didn’t want to educate
her.
She was also seriously ill as a child.
Nevertheless, she thrived under the guidance
of her brother, who taught her how to read
and write, and she passed the entrance exams
to attend university.
In his thirties, William settled in Boston,
again, doing menial jobs.
The media had a hay day when they found out
he was working as a lowly office clerk.
An unflattering article in a Boston daily
newspaper read:
“William J. Sidis, now thirty-nine, was
once declared by a group of eminent scientists
to be a coming innovator in the field of science,
with potentialities as great as Einstein and
as brilliant as Marconi.
Yet yesterday a Sunday Advertiser writer found
him in a small room, wall-papered and dark,
where for the past five years he has lived
unknown, unsung, uncaring.”
His health had also started to decline.
He was overweight and had high blood pressure,
which eventually caused a stroke.
The kind that claimed his father.
On July 17, 1944, William James Sidis died
of a cerebral hemorrhage which led to pneumonia.
He was 46 years old.
He was buried beside his father in New Hampshire.
Did William Sidis’ parents push him too
far?
A faculty member at Rice University, where
William briefly taught, disagreed.
Dr. Guérard believes: “He was the victim
not of intensive education given him by his
father, nor of the romantic curse called Genius,
but of the thoughtless cruelty of the public.”
The New York Times once excitedly described
William James Sidis as a "wonderfully successful
result of a scientific forcing experiment,
and as such furnishes one of the most interesting
mental phenomena in history."
As we now know, early success did not guarantee
a fulfilling and successful life.
If William had experienced a different upbringing,
the outcome of his life might have been entirely
different.
One thing that's certain is his exceptional
mastery of science and mathematics.
If you’d like to sharpen your skills in
STEM, I recommend Brilliant.org, a website,
and app where you can answer puzzling questions
like this:
A cup of warm water is suspended in a large
pot of water held at a steady boil.
Will the water in the cup ever boil?
Yes, no, or it’s impossible to say.
Assume the large pot never runs out of water.
The answer is that it will never boil.
As the cup of water heats up to 100°C in
the boiling pot, heat flow stops since both
are at the same temperature.
Brilliant can enhance your scientific thinking,
computer science, and math skills, giving
you a competitive edge in today's marketplace.
I use Brilliant to go through their Logic
courses which have improved my analytical
thinking.
For more puzzling questions like these, you
can try out Brilliant for free for 30 days
by heading to the custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who sign up with
my link will get 20% off their Premium subscription,
which gives you access to all the offerings.
Thanks for watching.
I’m Cindy Pom.